stunning increase in daily coronavirus
cases to more than 88
000 all that coming after a dip in late
summer
america has also just set a one-week
record for new cases
adriana diaz is in chicago where there
is no indoor service in bars and
restaurants
starting today adriana good morning
good morning tony these restrictions are
back because the positivity rate or that
the percentage of tests that come back
positive has crossed the threshold of
eight
percent now the governor hopes that
banning indoor dining will save lives
but the illinois restaurant association
calls the ban
a death sentence and this comes as cases
nationwide are so high
that listen to this it's the equivalent
of a new diagnosis
every second we need to clamp down
because we need to bring the numbers
down illinois governor jb pritzker says
surging coronavirus numbers have left
him
no choice but to ban indoor eating and
drinking
in chicago indoor socializing is growing
as the weather turns cold
says epidemiologist michael osterhome we
are now
seeing so many more people who are
congregating indoors
where we know the virus concentrates in
those set settings
and transmission is even increased as
cases continue to surge across the
midwest
michigan's governor tightened
restrictions on indoor gatherings
thursday
and officials in wisconsin warned
they're reportedly on the track to run
short of icu beds in two to six
weeks in south dakota the positivity
rate is an astonishing
46 percent meaning nearly half of all
tests are coming back positive people
are acting like there's
nothing going on and it's it's
absolutely maddening kathy james
son-in-law
56-year-old doug rasby contracted the
virus
he was an essential worker in the
agriculture industry in sioux falls
south dakota
and even though he was immunocompromised
he couldn't afford to stay home
his wife katrina was only able to visit
in person
on his last day i kind of got to say
goodbye but he wasn't
conscious and didn't really know that we
were there
the final conversations that we had with
him
um he just cried he said he was scared
and that he was going to die and that he
was going to die by himself
on facebook kathy james criticized south
dakota governor christie gnomes handling
of the virus
the governor recommends vulnerable
people stay home there's no statewide
mass mandate and the state has never
shut down we're on fire i mean
would if everybody wore masks would doug
have gotten it anyway
maybe but we'll never know
a spokesperson for south dakota's
governor says she has the family in her
prayers
and even one death is too many now gail
restaurants here in chicago
have had to get creative to stay afloat
in this pandemic and one way to do that
is with these
igloos which allow diners to eat outside
despite the city's dropping temperatures
yeah we hope they can figure out a way
to make it work but we still feel for
the woman who's just lost her husband
that's heartbreaking thank you adriana
very much